>> So one of the things that is going to be helpful as
a subcomponent to this process is to be able to say. Well,
if we've got a set of points in some space, and we're
trying to find the maximum likelihood Gaussian with some known variant. Mode is
the maximum likelihood Gaussian. What is the best way of setting the
mean to capture this set of points? So fortunately this is really easy
to do. And the reason that it works out this way is
the same reason that we've talked about in several of the other lessons.
But the maximum likelihood mean of the Gaussian, this mu that we want
to set, is the mean of the data, the mean is the mean.
>> That's pretty mean.
>> And it's no mean feat that it works out this way.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And, [LAUGH] what?
>> Oh, just well done.
>> So, in particular, this is really easy to compute. If we know that all
this data is coming from the same Gaussian,
then finding the mean that maximizes the likelihood
is just computing the mean of all the points.
>> Right, we kind of did that, just a few slides ago.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay, alright, so given a bunch of data
points that I all know came from some Gaussian, I
can compute the mean of that Gaussian by actually
taking the sample mean, and I could mean it, okay.
>> So the tricky thing of course, is what happens if there's k of them. How
do we set the k different means? And our answer is going to be, there I just
wrote it. Do you see it?
>> Nope.
>> That's because, it's hidden variables!
>> Oh. My favorite kind of variables.
>> Variables that you don't have to see. So what we're going to imagine is
that the data points, instead of just being x, it's actually x and a bunch of
random variables that are indicator variables on which
cluster that x came from. So it's not
just x anymore it's x and let's say a bunch of zeros and then a one.
Corresponding to which cluster generated X. Now of course if we knew that, that
would be really useful information. We, we're
going to have to do some inference to
figure out what those values are. But,
the, concept is that, by adding these extra
hidden variables in, it really kind of
breaks up the problem in a convenient way.
>> Okay.